uh there are there are many mistakes and
and I think every entrepreneur would say
that they've had a lot of mistakes to
manage through and hopefully you dodge
the big mistakes and the big ones don't
sink the ship and hopefully it's just a
bunch of small ones that you're able to
learn from and there's no doubt in my
mind that you learn more from your
mistakes than from all the things that
you do write in terms of mistakes and in
our case i would say i think i alluded
to this earlier i think raising a larger
round would have made sense at the time
we did a round of financing in 2007 sec
series b and and we did have the
opportunity to bump that round up and I
and I wish we had done it for a couple
million dollars more so but you know I
don't think anyone was anticipating some
of the other hurdles we would face
coming up but at but so that I think is
one one one mistake that I would have
would have done things a little bit
differently another is certainly in the
case of our magazine we we are an online
business ninety percent of our
businesses online we did something very
unusual in launching a print product
both because we believe it will be
profitable it has a great opportunity to
be a solid profitable business but it
also reinforces our overall brand and
the positioning of our brand however if
I were to do things differently I would
not have launched in the middle of 2006
I would have had us do a prototype for
it rather than actual printing of the
magazine we ended up burning through
some cash with actual manufacturing and
production of that magazine and I think
we should have done a prototype first
and then launched a little bit later
which brings me to a general lesson
which is think very hard about where
you're investing your money and if you
can figure out ways to take smaller
steps that are less costly to prove a
concept do it definitely you know
consider even if you have a large amount
of money on hand treat it as if you
didn't have a large amount of money on
hand and and see see about ways in which
to minimize your your risk exposure and
the use of cash because if you're going
to make a bad
if you're going to if you're going to
take a bad turn then it's better to lose
a little bit of money on that rather
than a lot